thumbnail this video yeah that's my
death that's death face ever and if it's
not I'll be too dead to care what
happened let's review something so
Flatliners is a remake of a movie from
1990 directed by Joel Schumacher by the
same name Flatliners there was a thought
or a collective rumor for a little while
that it was a sequel cuz Kiefer
Sutherland's in this movie - he was in
the originally plays the same guy he
does not play the same guy far as I can
tell it's not a sequel if it is a sequel
it doesn't really tie into the first
movie anyway and the premise of this
movie is very accurate - the trailer I
got to give the trailer props for not
lying to us group of med students that
get together and they ultimately stop
each other's hearts and bring each other
back so you can experience the afterlife
or having near-death experience
themselves but they flatline so I guess
it is an actual death experience then at
a point it kind of turns into a jump
scare fest sort of things coming after
them you don't know if it's a demon what
is it any movie just kind of unravels
and falls apart that was what the
trailer was that's exactly what this
movie is and I'll give the movie credit
where I was actually interested for the
first act of at the set up Ellen page's
characters kind of obsessed with the
concept of is there an afterlife is
there not is there a connection to the
dead that you can see if you die there's
a reason for that we've all asked that
question like what happens when I die
we're all going to have that happen you
watching this you're going to die I'm
going to die so we all ask ourselves
what's going to happen what am I going
to experience when I do die if anything
at all it is the constant that we all
have is the thing we everybody has in
common so the scientific research is
interesting to me because when they're
looking at the brain scans like a little
lightning bolts in the synapses you're
like oh is that the afterlife is your
brain doing that because there's a
connection to an afterlife or is that
happening in your brain giving you the
illusion of an afterlife I thought that
was really neat everyone ghosts and
come after them and I just checked out
because after that unique enough concept
that only a few movies have actually
touched on you're now experiencing a
movie that hundreds of movies a touched
on the movie in this second half just
got so choppy there's actually a scene
where a dude gets his hand stabbed the
very next shot he's sitting at a table
in a restaurant with his friends I was
like did that wrap up did he not get his
hand stabbed his hand is wrapped up in
God so I guess he did but it's oaring ly
fast it's just choppy as hell it would
have been more interested in this movie
if this movie actually just kind of
concentrated on them dying coming back
killing themselves reviving each other
just kind of like a drug where it's like
you can't keep doing this you're gonna
get severe brain damage although at one
point one girls out four easily six
minutes till brain damage is fine I know
the movie tries to be ambiguous as to
what's actually happening to them I
would have preferred the movie just
commit is it a ghost for a demon or are
they hallucinating this at a point
I thought they were gonna go the fringe
route they show fringe a soul of Fringe
there's this episode of Fringe that
deals with the concept of if your mind
believe something is happening to your
body your body will react to it like if
someone's under hypnosis and you make
them think that you're gonna burn them
with a cigarette and you touch their
hand their hand will actually blister I
don't know that's true or not but it's
interesting at least it looks like this
movie was going for that but in the end
it doesn't you see in the trailer Ellen
Page gets dragged across the ground body
reacting to what your mind thinks is
real or not you can't physically move a
human body unless something is moving a
human body now we have ourselves a cheap
scare movie that's not really a spoiler
for it I'm just telling you don't get
your hopes up and if you feel like I've
spoiled this movie for you in this
review it's Flatliners it's not
Star Wars if you give a tomorrow
you're officially giving this more
energy than it's worth and the pacing
sucks this movie it's about 20 minutes
too long and you feel it you feel it
hard by the end guys in the end
Flatliners was mad I give credit to the
first act because the first act actually
got me interested in the premise as a
whole I thought Ellen Page was good
everyone else was serviceable the movie
showed promise in parts but in the end
you walk out going the movies not that
interesting no one's gonna watch this
movie anyway I will say flat liners will
be forgotten in t-minus one day hey I've
already forgot alright guys so flat
liners have you seen it nope but what
did you think about it if you did or
what's the most interesting movie that
deals with death for you whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]